So here are the eight types. First, we have linguistics. This is the language
and verbal side of intelligence. This is our ability to understand and use both
written and spoken language. Next we have our mathematical logical type of
intelligence. This is the ability to analyse information and problems
logically, and to perform mathematical operations. For Spatial Intelligence,
this involves the ability to solve problems in three dimensional space. Next,
our Musical Intelligence involves the ability to perform or compose music, or
to hear patterns and recognize them. Bodily kinesthetic Intelligence, this
involves the capacity to use your whole body or parts of your body to solve
problems, make something, or carry out a performance. Next, we have our
Intra-personal Intelligence. This is the ability to understand, yourself, know
who you are, what you want, and understand how you're going to react to
different situations. Your Interpersonal Intelligence, this is your ability to
understand other people, what they're thinking, what they're feeling, or what
they're being motivated by. And finally, Naturalist Intelligence. This is
having the ability to understand and discriminate different living things, such
as plants and animals. And being aware and sensitive to one's natural world.